[Musique]
il ya quelques temps je vous ai parlé du
xps 13 de dell du modèle de l'année
dernière je détestais on l'a vu en sens
assez bien et on début d'année je vous
emmener si vous vous souvenez à las
vegas avec moi on a été voir les
nouveautés de dell et notamment ce
nouveau xps 13 de 2019 alors gelé reçu
il ya quelques jours je les tester s'il
est remis dans sa boîte pour faire un
bel effet il est beau il est bien il est
là dedans il est très intéressant et
surtout une nouveauté
grosse nouveauté vient parce que ça une
mise à jour c'est l'emplacement de la
caméra qui a changé qui étaient en bas
qui est passé en haut ça vous évite en
gros de vous filmer comme ça là et que
le nez proéminent tout le monde va voir
vous filmez d'en haut c'est un peu plus
joli pour partager avec vos amis pour la
visio compte pour du boulot pour tout ce
que vous voulez il ya une mise à jour
donc été fait cette année sur ce nouveau
xps 13 de dell je vous montre un peu
quelles sont les nouveautés
je vous dit ce que j'en pense d'aliments
sains tout qui est assez intéressant
voilà la bête voyez c'est franchement
compact c'est l'intérêt de cet xps 13
c'est qu'il est vraiment très compact
très fin très léger il fait quelque
chose comme un kilo de 1 kg 3 donc il
est franchement léger c'est un ultra
portable ça c'est vraiment un produit
qui est très intéressant parce que vous
glisser dans n'importe quel sac au jeu
vous l'emmenez facilement avec vous je
vous faire faire un tour de la
connectique très facilement vous avez
ici deux ports thunderbolt 3 vous avez
ici un port usb c'est un lecteur de
carte micro sd prise jack et c'est tout
voilà c'est tout c'est pratique c'est
sympa vous faites aujourd'hui tout avec
de l'usbc ou du thunderbolt roi c'est
franchement hyper cool vous le voyez on
reste toujours très compact il est très
fin
ça c'est vraiment l'intérêt d'un produit
comme celui là bon si assez minimaliste
vous avez ici un lecteur d'empreintes
digitales pour le déverrouiller y perd
facilement hop baffe bonjour bienvenue
monsieur heureux comme je vous le disais
le gros changement se situe ici au
niveau de la caméra des labos c en
recherche et développement pour réussir
à avoir un module caméra qui est
beaucoup plus petit et qui va s'intégrer
dans des bords très fin donc ça c'est
cool parce qu'avant il fallait chercher
le module caméra en bas et comme je vous
le dirai c'était pas terrible pour vous
filmez vous ça vous faisait un double
menton là c'est beaucoup plus sympa
mieux intégrer l'écran est cool c'est un
infiniti edge c'est une dalle épaisse de
13,3 pouces c'est du full hd 1920 par
1080 avec un format 16 9ème standard ça
marche écran assez lumineux puis à
presque isle could arrière si vous avez
toutes les techniques
elle del cinema des noirs plus profonds
des blancs plus brillant des couleurs
plus belle pour regarder des films des
séries ce que vous voulez youtube
compagnie ça c'est assez cool
alors pour moi c'est plus aux nordiques
qui va est destiné je dirais pour de la
bureautique vu que c'est un ultra
portable
rendez vous à l'emmener partout avec
vous jouant bien dit pour des étudiants
et être un petit peu plus cher pour des
étudiants mais pour le professionnel
c'est vraiment un ordi qui est vraiment
génial je vais penser à des commerces ya
tout ce que vous voulez c'est aussi un
ordi qui est performant vous avez un
intel core i7 dont celui là de huitième
génération alors vous pouvez partir de
21 core i3 intel core i5 intel core i7
est vrai que dans une toute petite
bécane comme ça vous avez quand même
vachement de puissance et pareil pour
avoir une version 4 gigas de ram 8 gigas
de ram 16 giga de ram
à vous de voir et pour le stockage vous
partez de 128 giga de stockage jusqu'à 2
tera de terreur je ne suis pas
nécessairement sur vous ayez besoin
d'avoir de tera d'autant plus que vous
connecter un disque dur en thunderbolt
roi ça va aller super vite ça
dépendamment de vos besoins ça dépend ce
que vous faites au niveau graphique
c'est une carte graphique intel hd 620
avec mémoire graphique partager ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien je trouve
que l'autonomie est assez bonne aussi
vous avez une batterie de 52 watts
je le garde disant à peu près 10 heures
sur le côté un peu bureautique
visionnage de films j'ai pas fait de
montages là dessus dès lors vous allez
installer un logiciel de montage
forcément l'autonomie salle à pomper
davantage mais pour du travail pour de
la bureautique pour du multimédia deezer
vous êtes tranquilles clavier bien
réussi c'est une version qwerty
mais rassurez-vous vous l'aurez en
azerty 1 pour l'avoir sur un clavier
européen je vais trouver certaines
touches un peu petit on a une course qui
est un peu longue par contre autant de
touches et franchement hyper cool et
côté touchpad ça fonctionne plutôt bien
bonne qualité ils marchent bien un
clic-droit clic gauche c'est cool c'est
sympa en plus ce qui est cool par là ils
vont retrouver le design fibre de
carbone qui est franchement hyper
séduisent - qui est aussi très important
c'est pas un ordi qui va chauffer même
lorsque vous utilisez sur des cessions
un peu un peu longue chauffe pas il se
ventile bien il est silencieux
ça c'est aussi hyper cool vous le voyez
vous savez la petite grille de
ventilation là il ya une bonne
répartition de la chaleur on tourne sur
un windows dix familles
rien de bien à dire là dessus ça
fonctionne parfaitement bien je vous
parlais de la caméra comme vous voyez
petite caméra qui est situé juste là
c'est beaucoup mieux profil mais c'est
tout de suite beaucoup plus
professionnelle que d'avoir cette espèce
de petite caméra vous êtes en hd 720
pixels c'est pas non plus un truc de fou
il faut faire de la visio conférence
pour parler à des amis se sont comme ça
ça fonctionne parfaitement bien il a des
haut parleurs stéréo vous en avez un ici
sur le côté il ya son petit frère qui
est juste là ici ça marche bien en
termes de son c'est pas mal c'est pas
complètement fou vous avez logiciel wave
max audio pro qui va permettre
d'optimiser tout ça est vraiment tirer
parti de l'audio de cette machine en
termes de tarifs
je prends mon paquet le tarif va
forcément varier en fonction des
configurations que vous allez avoir ça
je pense que vous vous en doutez si vous
partez par exemple sur un intel core i3
4 gigas de ram 128 g à de stockage vous
allez trouver à 1100 euros si vous
montez comme moi sur un i7 8 gigas de
ram 256 go de stockage vous arrivez à
1500 euros en fonction de la config que
vous vous allez vouloir si vous voulez
plus de stockage en ssd jusqu'à 2 tera
forcément ça va coûter beaucoup plus
cher mais ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant avec ce produit c'est que
vous avez un produit qui est petit et
compact qui est bonne qualité qui est un
excellent rapport qualité prix et qui
continue à toujours bien évolué c'est
pas un produit qui est tout nouveau
c'est pas un produit on va avoir un
effet waouh il ya eu une grosse
révolution pas du tout par contre ce qui
est bien c'est que évolution après
évolution des nous sort des produits
toujours plus sérieux toujours plus
intéressant le fait d'avoir changé cette
fois de cannes c'est très intéressant
est ce que ça montre surtout c'est le
travail de r&d qui est fait derrière en
termes de miniaturisation de caméras il
savait que derrière la caméra n'était
pas idéalement placé savais que c'était
un point de reproches sur ton ordinateur
du coup ils ont travaillé en recherche
et développement derrière pour trouver
toute petite caméra qu'ils ont réussi à
placer cette fois-ci idéalement et ça
c'est intéressant et c'est là où on voit
la force de frappe de dell d'aller
améliorer sa machine allez après année
vous proposer un ultraportable qui est
vraiment très intéressant
moi je trouve cool je sais pas vous ce
que vous en pensez qu est ce que vous
vous en pensez de cet expert stress de
il vous paraît bien oui non quoi comment
à savoir en plus que là je suis sur une
couleur qui est un peu standard de sur
angry un peu classique il ya une version
c'est frost je dis pas de bêtises
couleur blanche
très sympa et très lumineuse j'ai pas
tout ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que un produit comme
celui là pour vous tenter
est-ce que vous verriez bien avec un
petit hors du compact on est sur un
format je crois en châssis d'un 11
pouces si vous avez bien 13 pouces à
l'intérieur 13,3 pouces belle machine
belle autonomie belle performance format
compact ultra portable c'est intéressant
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaires et vous allez
bien évidemment à consulter materis qui
va vous aider à découvrir tous les ordis
du moment pc et compagnie maquis
compagnie voilà je vous embrasse je vous
dis à demain
prenez soin de vous et soyez sages
caoutchouc
non